[Applause]
a rollercoaster year for Sri Lanka
for many like vasanta mudaligi it will
continue the student leader has been
detained under Terror laws since August
months of shortages of food medicine
powdered milk fuel and gas combined with
up to 13 hour long power outages brought
people to the streets demanding
president gotabi rajapaksa his brother
the Prime Minister and his entire
Administration stepped down
we didn't expect this when we voted for
them for the leaders to destroy the
country for us and our children tensions
escalated When government loyalists
attacked peaceful protesters who had
been camped outside the president's
office for months in retaliation people
torched government vehicles and
ministers homes A Member of Parliament
was beaten to death in the violence that
followed
prime minister Mahindra rajapaksa was
forced to resign the president appointed
raniel vikrama singha as the new premier
that decision did not go down well with
protesters who wowed to continue their
campaign these are the scenes the
government is desperate to avoid
the crowds overran the president's house
forcing president rajapaksa to flee
first from his house and finally the
country and the sheer number of people
trying to get in to see the president's
house is posing a real problem the
protests really put the attention on the
political leadership and what the
political leadership could do and there
was now I think recognition that there
has to be political accountability
Vikram singer stepped into the void
voted in by the pro rajapaksa
parliamentary majority to complete the
presidential term
and he wasted no time in breaking up
demonstrations this clear out launched
at midnight on the day he took his oath
of office but the economic issues
haven't gone away
the crisis at the fuel pump and The
Wider Sri Lankan economy is far from
over despite the government's attempts
to show it has things under control
authorities say they have stabilized the
economy and are confident of bailouts
from the International Community
this crisis is primarily a governance
crisis that has manifested itself as a
crisis in the economy
and what's happening now is we are
trying to fix that economy without
fixing the governance
and I think that is set up to fail
president vicker messenger says he will
use the police and the military to
prevent disruptions and challenges to
the government's Authority that doesn't
face
and other protest leaders who say they
will not back down in 2023 Billa
Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo